Vào tụi gọi bột lần biê mi một bảo thuốc là sẽ gọi bạc.
Hãy đừng giải trị tổng vọng trụ của anh mà bảo tiê đang gửi tiênt thì
Bộ Bạy nói là hên năm mi ngìn,
thì có tụi thì thấy không thể bị rơ mi nhớ ra cái bị vẫn đẹp,
bình kiệt hãy tổng vỷ đi chăng rồi lời.
Bây giờ tổng vỷ bảo, là tiêng xanh, là tiêng.
Bộ bước chân là cửa cả trị cộ bạy gọi thăm chó này,
là chưa ra tiênt thì hánh chống nhà nào ra, lống thăm của mặt tổ vào xương quay hàng bên trái.
Cô tụi nả ra đường bị gửi chân đã gọi bộ bột lối năm bệ cai mặt lắm.
Bà này, vào bước.
Môi phút sau, thì tổ hết lâu thì tình đã gửi lực thì tổng vọng tổng vội.
Bây giờ, mình mùa sang đồ nó đã nhuy lâu,
là tôi gọi là xí mô một số, thì tổng vô chăm năm mi nhìn,
thì giảm ả chạy cả bà chân tôi thì tổ bất bự lửa đình đốt thì
bùng trái sang cho các quần, cho giải của đồ.
Bình vì không mình là chế vì cái đau đồn mắm,
thì mình thì không thể kiếm dễ quản thân dễ n mean,
đã thấy ở nâng.